francia ha alcanzado este martes la
cifra abrumadora de dos millones de
casos de kobe of house en francia esta
noche hemos pasado la cifra de dos
millones de casos del covent 19 con 2
millones 36 mil 755 casos confirmados
tanto en las zonas urbanas como las
rurales todas las regiones todos los
departamentos metropolitanos se ven
afectados por la epidemia pero de manera
heterogénea y de gestión
echegoyén se convierte así en el cuarto
país en superar los 2 millones de casos
aunque rusia que tiene el doble de
población les sigue estrechamente la
buena noticia es que la velocidad de
nuevos casos ha disminuido pero con 33
mil 500 pacientes actualmente
hospitalizados
la presión hospitalaria sigue siendo muy
alta
y difícil la situación de los hospitales
es muy difícil debemos mostrársela a los
franceses sigue siendo extremadamente
tenso no quisiera como digo ante esta
comisión el anuncio de una mejora que
estamos viendo todos vamos a estar
complacidos por eso es el propósito
mismo de las medidas
se han tomado pero no debemos dar la
impresión de que podemos bajar la
guardia de ninguna manera pese a un
claro que la pandemia de kobe debe
gestionarse a largo plazo por eso las
disposiciones para detenerlo persistirán
después del confinamiento que en un
principio corre hasta el primero de
diciembre